la question des observateurs donc je
traiterai aussi vous souhaitez en face
différemment mais je te retrait que la
question des observateurs du 1er mai
peut-être ça vous ça vous suffira moi
j'ai appris le 2 mai à neuf le 1er mai
par dont le premier mais excusez moi
j'ai appris le 1er mai à 9 heures lors
de ma prise de service à l'île de la
cité
que monsieur benalla serait présent
comme observateur sur le dispositif de
manifestation revendicative du 1er mai
je les ai appris de la bouche du numéro
trois de la démo pc c'est un contrôleur
général
pourquoi est-ce que je l'aï appris j'ai
les a pris puisque ce contrôleur général
à son bureau à côté du bien et qui se
trouve que le major de police qui était
le tuteur de monsieur ben alla le 1er
mai à son bureau en face donc aux cafés
comme quand vous venez au travail tous
les jours au café ce contrôleur général
lahmadi en discutant également avec le
major de police qui étaient présents que
monsieur ban à la serait présent en tant
qu'observateur il n'y avait aucune
question problématique soulevée à ce
moment là puisque nous accueillons très
souvent des observateurs moi même je
suis souvent désigné comme étant tuteur
candé organique comme des observateurs
viennent voir des services de l'ade et
aux pc je les fais sur les quatre
derniers mois avec un journaliste de m6
par exemple l'inde enquête exclusive des
mois je les fais avec un membre du
cabinet
du préfet de police il se trouve que là
le premier mais je n'étais pas désigné
je n'étais pas désigné comme étant le
tuteur de monsieur le maire puisque
c'était le major de police
j'ai eu cette information simplement
parce que nous partageons les presque
deux bureaux nos trois bureaux sont
voisins
j'ai eu cette information dans ce
cadre-là par la suite sur cette question
de monsieur kraz moi je n'avais jamais
vu monsieur crâne 1er mai je ne
l'identifié pas et d'ailleurs j'ai
appris ça son identité un monsieur crade
ainsi que son statut de mémoire le le 19
juillet lors du point presse de monsieur
bruno roger petit jeune a pris à ce
moment là